the Joe Rogan experience what got you
what when did you make the switch to
Apple in the first what was it thing
forever forever but what was the genesis
at some point you had to have had like a
sanyo yeah
59 that was my old flip phone shout-out
to seeing you I remember when I was in
radio back home in Birmingham I was
gifted an iPod Touch oh yeah and I was
all Android phones Android everything
and I had an iPod Touch and at the time
all I had said played music was a
minidisc player so I could only hold
like five hours I mean this is like oh
102 and I had a five hour mini disc
[ __ ] I'll carry around an iPod
Touch and then it made more sense why am
i carrying an iPod Touch and an Android
phone when I could just have an iPhone
that does both and that started the
journey I started with iPhone one but
before that I was using mac books I was
using Mac forever but even before they
had an iPhone I used to make my own pcs
I used to go to the store like go to
fries by motherboard by hard drive never
had no time for that you got it you got
a want to do that like it was for me I
was well I wanted to find out how to do
it and it was it was cool to play games
on a computer that I put together myself
but then you knew how to lie so you're
building the games as well you got a
floppy disk no I'm not definitely not
building eight games I would just you
know I video games just play among the
same but even formatting it and doing
everything I would have to call friends
that really knew what the [ __ ] was up
and they'd have to talk me through [ __ ]
there's some things you have to do in
the BIOS and you know the irony of all
of this is that I still have an AOL
email address as much as I I don't
understand
email slander my [ __ ] it's I'm sending
you words electronically does it matter
company what is it is my email more
ghetto does it come with chicken grease
stains when you open it in your laps no
it's the same words that if I sent it
from Gmail now I have a gmail account so
that people will take me seriously when
I email them about business ideas but I
still have an old-school AOL email that
I've had since college
and I'm like it's fine it's a one it's
one of those things though wouldn't you
just don't let it go I just think about
you've got mail remember when you first
heard that you've got man happy you know
someone was to talk to me it was very
exciting who to talk to me and then you
get older and you realize well please
leave me alone
who the [ __ ] is this no you got mail
yeah it was exciting it was like a new
thing
[Applause]